welcome to the pink marketing show the
number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
I'm Heather Torres and I'm Sean Connell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening welcome
this show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content notice and
the latest money-making strategies
working right now online so whether you
want to grow your YouTube channel or
maximize online video across social
media this is for you
so today we have something really
special for you we hosted our sold-out
video marking marketing conference grow
as video live where we dope into the
latest strategies for video marketing
and online business shout out to
everyone from the think community who
came to that and this year it was just
electric we brought together the think
media team we had guests and it was just
amazing to see just the power that's
happening right now in online video and
today we're bringing you Sean candles
keynote from that event now what I loved
about this keynote specifically was that
Sean really shared his journey he talked
about how he was a college dropout and
now he's running a multi-million dollar
media company Sean's gonna share with
you some of the latest video stats that
you need to know right now and how it's
gonna affect your business this year
also how to stay motivated so you can
keep creating content all year long and
why now is the best time to be using
online video for your business so let's
jump over to the keynote now we're gonna
kick it off right now with just our
first session all about kind of get on
the same page of what's the future of
online video right now and and why
should we go all-in and what's that all
about but as we mentioned our mission
here is to help you build your influence
with social media and in this session
we're gonna be talking about some must
know stats and online video trends ten
reasons to go all-in with online video
right now as well as how to stay
motivated to create social media content
and to push through you know when we
sometimes things get tough but if we're
just meeting my name is Sean and my
background
is I live now here my wife in Las Vegas
with my wife Sonia our two chihuahuas
but we actually started and grew up in
Washington State
right maybe you've heard of Seattle
before Washington's pretty pot even yet
Starbucks starting there of course
Microsoft Nirvana Macklemore come on all
coming out of the Northwest and so
Amazon of course it's like a tech
culture that's what's amazing about
Washington is its tech its future
thinking Seattle but that's actually not
where I grew up I actually did not grow
up anywhere near release yet I grew up
in the country it was it was Arlington
Washington I got my parents in the front
row here we grew up come on come on we
grew up like we grew up on six acres we
had like quads and like doats and some
horses yeah it kind of crazy stuff
here's me I mean I was in a tree you
know this is before social media you
know that kind of parents are like I
wish my kids would go outside we did
because we didn't have anything else we
didn't have power
just kidding we had power but you know
what I love about this is is you know I
grew up in and didn't have like any
connections in Hollywood and no one
really in our family was was into like
you know video or that kind of stuff but
it just shows you the power that when
you just punch fear in the face and you
press record and you can just start in a
bedroom that amazing things can happen
and for me I actually got started in my
local church 2003 I started shooting
video and you can see it's just a ragtag
group there I actually the person that
got me into video his name's Jeff
Moore's who's my youth pastor he's
sitting right over here Jeff stand up
just so people get there we probably
wouldn't be here if it wasn't for Jeff
Moore's and man we were ballin on a
budget though you could see those home
depot lights and the screens there right
that was some that was green screen from
jo-ann fabrics right some of you might
relate you're like I don't got much
money right um I got my phone and some
duct tape and that's all you need but uh
and then for years I was waiting tables
at Red Robin and and and then doing
videos for my church and just kind of
learn in video and my first videos were
my worst videos just like yours right
but you were kind of building those
muscles getting through it then in 2009
I started a video production business
and
got a little bit deeper into video and
and it wasn't think media it was in 2010
that think media actually started and I
uploaded my first video on that channel
and we saw a little bit of it but let's
check it out just kind of take it back
for a moment alright so this is I guess
the first Sean thinks vlog and I'm gonna
try to vlog every single day mainly so I
can remember what I'm even doing and
what's going on because I just feel like
I have a lot that I'm thinking about and
I figured hey why not share it and if
you find something interesting that's
awesome now this is definitely as real
as it gets
so I'm not gonna try to be energetic or
entertaining though maybe sometimes I
will anyways yeah yeah man you know you
know that just that really reminds me of
this quote by Zig Ziglar and it's this
you don't have to be great to start but
you have to start to be great you got to
just start you got to just press record
and that's what I did and and now we've
seen the power of online video over
these last years of course not just in
the world but in our business I mean
going from just shooting videos in a
bedroom to now building a multiple
seven-figure company it's been crazy to
see the power of social media and online
video and so as we start today let's
talk about why online video and I'm kind
of preaching to the choir I mean you
already have Pam here to grow with video
but there's some very interesting stats
we need to know in regards to where
videos going and even where it is right
now
you know Cisco says that by 2022 online
video will make up more than 82 percent
of consumer Internet traffic that's 15
times higher than it was in 2017 this is
the rapid acceleration of video period
and consumers by the way those are the
people you're trying to reach whether
that's with your products services as an
influencer video is the format it's it's
what's growing more than anything else
78% of people watch online videos every
week and
55% of people view online videos every
day who's in that 55% that's me man
every single day like I'm probably
seeing some kind of online video six out
of ten people would rather watch online
videos than television
and yes culture shifts it's funny my
wife Sonia and I often times will sit
down after a day's work we turn on our
Smart TV and we don't go anywhere else
we go to youtube first turn around Phil
DeFranco I get filled in on my news
you know I turn on a couple other we go
through our subscriptions it's
interesting how culture is shifting in
fact you could see it here that the TV
consumption is going down why online
video it has surpassed that and it's
going up in terms of here in the US time
spent consuming content now on social
media where you're going to be reaching
your target audience the people you want
to reach social media posts with video
have 48 percent more views than post
without video and social video generates
1,200 percent more shares than text and
image content combined so uploading
video not just YouTube but uploading
video on Twitter on Instagram on
LinkedIn on these different platforms is
very powerful for getting more reach now
65 percent of people use YouTube to help
them solve a problem in this room you
could write this down and I hope you're
taking notes throughout this conference
even just even if you throw them away
after it helps us kind of retain the
information we're learning but when I
think about this here's what question
all of us need to answer what problem do
you solve you got to know that and when
you know that people are going to the
Internet to go to Google they go to
YouTube to help solve a problem and
maybe that's how to get more views on
YouTube or how to save money on your
taxes or how to have a stronger
relationship or how to go deeper in your
faith whatever it is and people are
looking for answers on YouTube you need
to be showing up with those answers now
a website is 53 times more likely to
reach the front page of Google if it
includes video so as business owners
having video integrated on our website
embedded in different posts very
critical to get more reach on our
websites and then nearly 50% of Internet
users look for
videos related to a product or service
before visiting a store so with what
we're seeing now is is is online video
being kind of a synergy of what's
happening off line and so you want to
have any kind of product you have any
kind of service you have you want video
describing that educating about that
because even people want to research you
first kind of stock you a little bit
online and then maybe do business with
you later now this is where it gets
crazy
three point four eight billion people
roughly forty five percent of the
world's population use social media no
no half the world is active on social
media and you don't need to be told in
this room that like this is where the
future is going but for some business
owners and here's the opportunity at our
kind of networking party I was talking
to a couple different people about their
industries I was talking to people
especially whether it's the residential
service industry or maybe some kind of
traditional business industries where
they're like you know our people aren't
quite online yet here's the thing we're
seeing them all come online and one out
of two people on planet earth are on
social media apps you need to be on
social media apps right now here's the
breakdown of the monthly active users on
the key platforms by the way these are
the platforms that pretty much we think
are relevant when it comes to video
right now you active on Twitter you have
326 million people active on Twitter
LinkedIn probably one of the most
important platforms for us as
professionals to be active on right now
uploading video content as well as text
pictures 260 million monthly active
users on that platform it's the
wealthiest social network out of all of
them regardless of users because it's
where business is done it's where
professionals are it's where brands are
people on LinkedIn have money so if you
are looking to do business build your
income you want to be active on LinkedIn
tik-tok is hot right now now raise your
hand if you know what tick tock is and
you have the app raise it hi I'm just
got to survey the room not too bad not
too bad so maybe 20% of the room so
tick-tock right now some are saying is
the biggest threat to like an Instagram
which is one of the hottest platforms
right now something to kind of put on
your radar definitely a younger
demographic but that's always where it
starts and then things usually age up so
something to be paying attention to of
course Instagram Facebook YouTube
massive saturation here's the bottom
line when you get your marketing right
your messaging right you get your
business set up right your communication
right your customers are here there is
no shortage of customers for you there's
just you needing to reach them and
connect with them there's no sort of
shortage of money in the economy for
your business there's no reason you
should not be prospering I get it you
got it it's it's tough in it there's a
struggle and different thing but there
are this is an insane amount of people
it's about getting in front of them on
by the way every single one of these
platforms is free to use free to use in
celebration of the launch of this brand
new podcast we're giving away two
tickets to our annual conference grow as
video live a fifteen hundred dollar
value all you have to do to enter is
make sure you subscribe leave us a
review on Apple podcast and then take a
screenshot of your review and go to
think marketing show.com
for the rest of the details now we're
gonna go and talk just about phones a
little bit we're gonna talk about smart
phones nearly three-quarters of the
world will use just their smart phones
to access the internet by 2025 so what
we need to be aware of as we think it's
kind of the broad reach of this is also
that right now the screen that you're
gonna be reaching the people that you
need to reach is right here that this is
the window to the world and that not
only is that true now but it's
increasingly true by 2025 three-quarters
of the earth will be will have this
device so therefore you can reach them
on these platforms 51% of time spent
online is spent on mobile devices and so
through all the people on the internet
over half and that number is growing the
majority are on mobile now the average
US adult will spend two hours this is
where it gets kind of awkward and 55
minutes on their smart phone
per day anybody is that you that's me
they say they say some people they say
that's the average they say crazy people
it's over five hours is for five hours
it's very rare we have people like point
people I yeah haha that's so funny and
so uh so the average adult yeah two
hours on their phone now the majority of
that time is being spent on social media
so out of that almost three hours two
hours and 23 minutes per day is on
social media what is the point I'm
trying to make this is the device that
we're gonna be reaching people and the
main thing that people are using on this
device of social platforms those social
platforms are free and you creating
relevant content that's valuable to get
in front of your target audience is
massively powerful this graph right here
also shows us the increase since 2012
and so what's the trend of online video
this isn't slowing down this is going up
we see this continuing to grow and so
there's massive opportunity for us now
here's how many times we touch our
phones per day the typical cell phone
user touches his or her phone 2617 times
per day so this is including touching it
typing on it right like doing some stuff
maybe play a game or something or if
you're like me if you're just compulsive
and every once in a while you look
around you just touch it how do you ever
do that I'm on meetings I'm listening
like Heather and Melissa talk for a
second and then I'm like okay and I
start zoning out I just start like and
I'm like all right should be listening
and and it's like and I write and that's
just the average user extreme cell phone
users the top 10% they touch their
phones 5400 times a day
look at the person next to you and say
you've got a problem you've really gotta
Brahmi
yeah no no no now here's the deal you
came to grow with video I'm not here to
like preach about whether this is good
or bad
that will be bed up to the psychologists
you know I'm not here to discuss any of
those things but for us as business
owners we just need to understand that
this is true and that whether what you
know whether it's healthier
regardless there's a lot of opportunity
there because people are glued to these
things
scarily so isn't it I mean I've been
driving lately I'm seeing this just
yesterday I got my hair cut I was going
through this parking lot I saw this
woman man she was just whipping through
the parking lot just she wasn't even and
I was I was like dear God
oh my god if I wasn't I would have died
if I was in front I watched the whole
thing happened luckily she was
unobstructed but but again well I'm not
here to discuss those things I'll leave
that up to the psychologist this is
massive opportunity for you and me this
is where attention is this is where you
need to be now
finally digital audio curveball digital
audio accounts for the biggest share of
time spent on these mobile devices well
Sean this is a video conference yes but
what the stats show us is actually that
what people are listening to the most is
audio and then it says social medias
next and video is third so right now on
our phones people are spending the most
time on audio then they're spending time
on social media and then they're
consuming video what we're gonna be
talking a lot about at this conference
is video podcasting it is our belief
that many of us in this room I believe
all of us should be focusing on digital
audio considering to start a podcast who
already has a podcast wave of me awesome
so a few people in the room now when you
video podcast what's amazing is you get
all of these because if you record the
audio as well with video you can hit
YouTube you can also hit the podcast you
can go on Spotify now for free right you
can upload clips in social media put
content on YouTube so by doing a video
podcast that is the strategic way to
dominate and we're gonna be going a lot
deeper in that throughout the day so
what's the point
and it's time to go all in like it's
time to go all in like you came to Vegas
to sit here at grow his video not to go
all in at the back to blackjack -
blackjack tables blackjack tables but to
go all in and video and what I mean by
that is like again this is where
people's attention is like the the
statistics are in the results are in
this is modern marketing and this is
also where its most underpriced can you
still do billboards and do people see
them sure can you still do television
ads absolutely can you still do radio
absolutely but these are free platforms
we also highly encourage and we'll be
discussing paid traffic on these
platforms but this is where it's
happening and when I say go all-in what
I mean by that is that we got a really
lean in I mean you already bought a
ticket to this conference and you're
here but when I say it's not just about
money this is about our time it's about
our energy it's about our strategy it's
about really putting our you know heart
our strength our emotions into this
because the opportunity is that big and
I've learned that half-hearted efforts
never get great results that that's
someone that is your competitor and
someone in your industry they are going
all-in and so they understand this
opportunity and they're jacked up
they're fired up and they're leaning
into this you're here to make that
decision today if there's one thing I
want you to take away from this session
maybe even this conference is that you
would say man I'm gonna commit to this
thing I see it the writing's on the wall
it is time to go all-in look at your
neighbor and say go on and tell them
that look at the person on the other
side and say you really need to go
all-in you really you especially I mean
yeah but here's the problem here's the
problem like I said you probably you're
hearing you're like yeah I mean that's
why I'm here how about a ticket man
you know I flew from New York bro I mean
I got my gum all in the the problem I
think is this stat right here it's not
that we we don't know that we need to go
all in but eighty three percent of
marketers would increase their reliance
on video if and in strategy if there
were no obstacles like time resource and
budgets and so that's that's what we're
talking about today we're gonna talk
about and Heather's gonna be sharing a
little bit about productivity and how do
we actually optimize some of these
things so we can implement them in our
business you know if we had more
resources if we had more budget but you
know what that looks like to me most
marketers are making excuses most up
marketers are being a little sissies for
real man like I would do a lot of things
like man I would be in a lot better
shape if I had more time resources and
motivation you know I mean like that's
everything like you know I love this
quote from Thomas Edison opportunity is
missed by most people because it's
dressed in overalls and it looks like
work you got to go all-in and we got to
overcome these obstacles and that's what
we're gonna do today and one of the
things that we've learned as it pertains
to going all-in is it's not enough to
really just have kind of like mental
comprehension but it actually needs to
be something that we truly buy into at a
heart level we like to say that reasons
come before results reasons come before
results when you've got strong enough
reasons that gets you up and motivated
to do the extra work that maybe after a
hard day's work in your business your
life son I mean I'm maxed out I got
client calls I got stuff to do I got
delivery of services I got all this
stuff that when you get home after a
hard day's work you go but I get this
online video this video podcasting
thing's real so I'm gonna hustle an
extra hour two hours three hours four
hours to get in that extra time but you
have to have strong enough reasons to do
that you know that reminds me of of
really my drive in my motivation and it
kind of goes back to when we were in the
hardest
season of our life you may have heard
our story before but my wife Sonia and I
we actually got married in 2000 when we
were 21 we got married in 2005 we just
celebrated our 14th anniversary
September 9th
thank you and so we got married young we
got married at 21 and and it was yeah
yeah yeah and so we're just young couple
you know we've got big dreams young
vibrant like just ready to take on the
world
but in just and at the time we were we
were hustling this I do dementia I
started my business in 2009 so I was
doing my business clear vision media my
wife Sonya had multiple jobs she's
working at Starbucks she's waiting
tables she was nanny nanny for some
friends of ours
I was waiting tables at Red Robin and
that's not actually how my hair looked
that was Halloween I was Wayne from
Wayne's world at that time would have
been awesome though I mean I think maybe
I should do that that's a bro a video
next year if I start now and we were
kind of dabbling on YouTube and we were
we were going all these things but then
we hit the hardest season of our life
and after we got married just two years
later my wife got very sick she actually
went on a trip to the Philippines and
and came back we didn't know what's
going on and she's throwing up
five 10 15 times a day for a few years
doctor after doctor after doctor had no
idea what was going on and over two
years she began to lose all this kind of
weight and eventually got to a place
where she was hospitalized and almost
died and I found myself in the hospital
room with her for six days just kind of
by her bedside trying to figure out my
what are we gonna do what are we gonna
do next and if that wasn't enough some
of you could probably relate to going
through the the the big short like that
the crash the economy 2008-2009 and we
were going to that time to we'd actually
had a rental property we had a house and
so now we're dealing with chronic
illness we're dealing with kind of job
loss and now we're losing our homes and
you can imagine the weight and the
pressure of that and if if that wasn't
enough I mentioned I Scott started in
church right and I was working at that
church well at that church some people
stole some money and things started
falling apart there was this massive
Ansem and movement but it just began to
just fall to pieces and now you also had
people you trusted and people you looked
up to that lets you down and so we
really felt like like man what is
happening like things were literally
falling apart all around around us we're
losing money we're losing our homes well
I have no idea what's gonna happen with
my wife's health what our future holds
and maybe you can relate to a season
like this right maybe right now you're
in a season like this or or you can look
back to a season like this dealing with
uncertainty overwhelm right you're
scared like you're afraid and and it was
during this season that I really
realized man life is short you get
punched in the face with this kind of
stuff at a super young age and it kind
of wakes you up to like whoa like like
life is short and begin to ask questions
like man are we really maxing out and
like living like at the highest level
made me think like man am I really
spending quality time with my family and
I have I really spent quality time with
my wife do I have that freedom to spend
time with her because in a moment maybe
she could be gone maybe I could be gone
in a moment and you start to think about
these things you know and then who was I
really as as a man and as a leader you
know I was working in ministry I was
waiting tables and trying to get my
business going we weren't doing great
financially and now as we were dual
income she's losing jobs so I'm like man
I got to step up and I actually got to
really lead and begin to fight reasons
come before results and it was during
this season that I began to capture new
reasons like man I gotta fight for my
family come on I got it hold tight to my
faith I got a really believe that we can
still have a good future and that we can
get through this obstacle if we keep
going and we keep learning what I want
you to do is write down some reasons
right now and the reason we're doing
this I know you're here for strategy and
tactics we're going to get those today I
know you're here for the latest things
we're gonna do those today but what I've
learned is that this is the stuff that
really matters friends that when we
really are going to get through what's
coming in terms of the the uphill battle
of winning on social media the uphill
battle of standing out in your niche and
and learning these new skills you got to
have strong reasons and you know as
you're writing I wanted you just
brainstorm right
anything down it doesn't have to be
super deep you know what like I had that
dream vacation where is that write it
down I've got that that car that I want
write that down but then maybe what is
it that you're fighting for man I'd love
to be able to support this cause I would
love to be able with just with no
problem at all to be able to just write
a check to this organization that I care
about you know I want my son my daughter
to have this kind of future I want her
to see mom and dad doing this or maybe
dad left your single mom and you're like
I want my legacy to be this let's
capture some reasons and as you're
writing for the rest of this session I
just want to talk about 10 reasons to go
all-in with online video right now these
are some of the reasons that I had that
kept me motivated to go through the
struggle because you know we're standing
on stage right now and we're here at
grow a video but I shot that first video
in 2010 y'all and I got started a video
in 2003 right so there was a lot of
uphill fights to go through to get where
we are today so I had to have strong
reasons number one these are just some
reasons that maybe you could pull into
your life as well but here's some for me
become a creator not just a consumer
creators are the ones that win in the
new economy there's plenty of consumers
there's plenty of people that want to
watch content and I love I'm a consumer
as well love watching but when you step
out and start creating content it
actually kind of does something in your
life you start contributing value to the
world you start creating something
meaningful become a creator not just a
consumer second reason you get to create
community I mean this is insane friends
like we're here like inner circle for
dr. K's right here like in ER people
know like David Goldstein's back here I
wouldn't be sitting on this stage if it
wasn't for him either like it's crazy
all these like that you're meeting
people like we're in a room we're in
Vegas the Sahara Hotel community happens
because you step out and you start
creating content it actually makes me
think of Nicole who's here where's
Nicole at hey Nicole and so it makes me
thinking to go she's the kids
occupational therapist she punched fear
in the face started posting videos and
she's helping other moms on her Channel
so her she has something like 40,000
subscribers but you can kind of see her
stats on the screen she's growing by
2072 subscribers per month it's cool
right
and that's 2072 mom's right that are
trying to figure out how to get their
newborn to latch that was awkward okay
so you know haha it's my favorite thing
okay and but she's helping people and
community is forming she's meeting
strangers and now they're becoming
friends and so creating community number
three is to express your creativity now
I want to attack a myth right now some
of you are you like that's mine yo I'm
an artist yeah you know that's that's
natural for me some of you in this room
have believed the myths that you're not
creative that's not true all of us are
creative I know that God has wove
greatness into all of our DNA and your
creative into in your own way see
sometimes we think creative is just
creativity is just video but creativity
is problem solving creativity is
figuring out how to run a team
creativity is figuring out how to raise
some kids without them going crazy and
burning your house down like expressing
your creativity but when you start to
share content on the Internet
you get to put out creativity but I've
learned that creativity is unlocked by
commitment creativity is unlocked by
commitment and so that's when we when we
go all-in when we go all-in then we
start saying look there's no turning
back it's kind of like burning the ships
burn the boats because now it's like we
better find a creative solution like you
know we're gonna do this video once a
week come hell or high water I'm
uploading a video once a week no matter
what and then you start getting creative
to figure out how it's done you start
thinking oh shoot it's Tuesday the
videos got to come out well I guess I'm
shooting all night long and I'm gonna be
creative with what caffeine beverage I
choose you know what I mean like you
find a way where there's a will where
there's a way commitment unlocks
creativity number four I've learned that
the reason I started to discover this
when I started to create content make
videos stretch myself put myself out
there that it has been the number one
catalyst of my personal growth
that it's been stretching challenging
post some videos get a few negative
comments that are deeply personal and
accurate about you start makes you grow
a little bit challenges you a little bit
right and so by stepping out a video of
my skills grew from just doing it my
confidence grew a knowledge group
problem-solving resilience these things
grow by just stepping out and committing
like these are reasons right because we
haven't even got to like profit or
anything when you've got strong reasons
you just go people go what your channels
not growing that fast your podcast is
not growing that fast you're like it's
all good man I'm good I'm getting my
muscles bigger right now I'm not ready
to compete in the Ironman yet I'm just
in the gym working it out my reasons is
the personal growth I'm gaining from a
commitment to this process reason number
five build a portfolio so powerful once
you start sharing your voice your
message your answers your value on the
internet LinkedIn Instagram you're
building a portfolio a portfolio of
content makes me think of Diana and
Diana right now is actually back on the
cameras yeah we were just
she actually recently joined the thick
media team doing some she's independent
she helps us with some micro content
that you might see on my Instagram and
whatnot 2016 had a full time job had a
lot of responsibilities had all this
kind of stuff but she committed and went
all-in
she's uploaded 238 videos on her channel
over the last three years now now her
channel has is amazing but as two
thousand seven hundred subscribers not
two million not two hundred thousand two
thousand seven hundred three years two
hundred and thirty-eight videos that's
commitment man that's how so but but
in just the last like two months in fact
shout it out she just was able to quit
her jobs have no bosses become
completely her own entrepreneur women
running her own business yeah now she's
trying to hire people she needs to hire
people to help her because of the amount
of clients she has how long you been
full-time Diana May 10th
she knows the day the day she was able
to say come on helping 10,000
entrepreneurs become full-time doing
what they love with online video it's
possible but I've been so inspired by
you Diana because you've been all in and
you've been all in when it's been hard
and when it hasn't been super sexy or
super flashy but she hasn't give up and
and she made it and she's been building
a portfolio of work that is super
inspiring I think about the portfolio
that we're building on think media I
believe this that every video I upload
is a contribution to my body of work
it's part of my life's legacy and so as
I'm uploading videos now and this was
true back in 2010 11 12 that I was like
okay what you know I'm thinking you were
like this isn't very significant yet I'm
like well yeah just give me 10 years
right it's all a contribution to your
legacy your life's work a strong
portfolio also leads to unlimited future
business when you've got a strong
portfolio on these social platforms
that's what Diane is experiencing that's
what we're experiencing at think media
you build a strong portfolio and
eventually literally we have more
business than we could ever handle like
more people like inquiries than we could
ever handle why because we built a
sports strong portfolio not overnight
but over time number six get discovered
we talked about it people looking for
answers like as business owners as
influencers that want to make profit one
of our big challenges like yo Shawn
though but what if like nobody knows me
yet well yeah that's how we all started
y'all you know what I mean like nobody
knew anybody when they first started but
you have to just start posting but
what's so powerful is that you can get
discovered write this down and think
about this what is it you want to be
known
what is it you want to be known for you
have to be able to answer that question
and then you can start getting
discovered for that thing that you want
to be known for well Sean I want to be
known for these 15 things you're
probably never gonna get discovered for
that because if it's too broad but when
you become when you know what you want
to be known for that'll be that'll help
you reverse engineer your content and
then you could get discovered we know
that YouTube is the second largest
search engine in the world arguably
there's we wouldn't be here at this
event if it wasn't for that single fact
and once I discovered that in video
ranking Academy members understand this
that people are going to YouTube looking
for answers to their questions and when
nobody knows you they know their
question they type it in and if you show
up in search on the other side of that
search result now somebody who doesn't
know you knows you you get discovered
and now you have a chance for them to go
deeper with you in business maybe just
watch more free content maybe join your
email list maybe discover your products
we've got people that are in video
ranking Academy real estate agents and
they that people discover their video
and in the top 3 lines of text they've
got their phone number and their email
so they can just get on the phone and
sell houses or do mortgages and so you
can get discovered LinkedIn I just
pulled this up because we've been active
over there
in the last 90 days 1984 people have
viewed my profile we're putting out
strategic content a lot of people who
had no idea who I was are discovering me
because I'm taking action and posting
content on these strategic platforms
keep writing your reasons writing your
reasons what are your reason I built in
your reasons the fuel that's gonna fuel
you as you're building your brand online
number seven is personal branding
there's may be no greater accelerator
for building a personal brand than
publishing content on-line personal
branding is so important because even if
you just stay in it you want to just
accelerate in your career more than ever
before people that are seeking people to
join their companies that want they want
to hire people what do they do they go
look at them online I'll tell you of
course we're a social media company but
nobody would make it to think media if
we don't look at their Instagram page we
don't look at that we look at their
we look at the kind of content that
we're putting out there we're curious
what are they all about we're curious
about every post you post on social
media is building your personal brand
like out of the overflow of the heart
Facebook Twitter and YouTube speaks like
you know if I if I go to your Facebook
page and I just see like 26 outraged
political crazy comments or whatever I
go okay this is who this person is right
we're building our legacy we're building
our brand but when you are publishing so
what do you want to be known for reverse
engineer back for that consistently
publish content around that and then
eventually like how did I become the
YouTube guy I started talking about
YouTube a lot for a long time and then
it was like dude you're like the YouTube
guy yeah why because you were talking
about it for a lot for a long time so
when you're known for the one thing you
want to be known for talking about it it
builds your personal brand and then like
you with a strong personal brand
companies want to hire you like you're
in demand people want to work with you
why are they going to pick one
consultant one coach one advisor over
somebody else personal brand they look
them up online they start stocking your
Instagram page we got to be thinking
about these things I love this quote
from Jay Z I'm not a businessman I'm a
business man right do you got to be
thinking about that and and this might
be a switch that some of you in this
room want to make one of my mentors
chalene johnson told me that she says
shaun eventually you have to decide what
are you using social media for are you
using it for business or using it for
personal and if you're using it for
business then go all-in and using it for
business like if you're using it for
personal who even cares about any of
this stuff just just have like your few
close friends and your few family follow
you and be clear about that but if
you're using it for business it's
probably time to go all-in for business
to stop trying to blend it to stop
trying to worry about it and to make
every action decision intentional to
create the end result that you want
because you're a business man
alright number this is a good reason
number uh number eight make money make
money right and so when you what are
your reasons I mean I first sure started
back in 2010 and in kind of my journey
was I was discovering that there was the
power of of ranking videos YouTube as a
search engine and I discovered something
called affiliate marketing affiliate
marketing and and that's where you could
sign up for a site like amazon.com and
if you recommend a product if I talked
about a camera and I put a link in the
description below and someone clicked
that link and they purchase something
then I would get a commission on that
and so if I was talking about a camera
or lighting but on my personal channel I
was doing videos I was like reviewing
health products I was doing these gift
ideas videos during Christmas or
whatever else and here's the deal
I really want to make a difference in
the lives of people I want to make an
impact but I'm not trying to say like
I'm just some saint here I'm trying to
make some money man is that fair
anybody else trying to make some money
come on you you you need you need
provision for the vision like you're not
gonna be doing this very long if you
don't got any money coming in and so so
one of my reasons was like yeah I'm
doing this I want to add value of course
lead with value of course not be you
know Sully you're weird but but there's
got to be connected to profit right I
think about doctor I help where's he at
he's here doctor I health right there
man good to have you here
this is crazy man Joseph he's a doctor
of Optometry and he he started posting
videos on his YouTube channel and it's
just been going crazy in fact these are
his stats right here 4209 subscribers
he's growing per month right now yeah
yeah he's an inner-circle video ranking
Academy and check it out four videos a
month four videos a month one a week
somebody gonna do more but that's what
we recommend like when we sum this all
up if you're like Sean what's my
strategy what's my game plan if it's
anything like it doesn't need to be that
crazy one thing a week one video a week
one video podcast a week we'll hit that
more but he's been doing some cool stuff
building his income a little bit with
affiliate marketing but he just asked
him recently how some things are going
he he's going to be sitting on a panel
as the YouTube guy in November at a
conference in San Francisco called
I innovate digital marketing for I
doctors all right so so he's building
his personal brand right and money
starting to come in and he's a creator
not just a consumer he's doing all these
things
he's momentum starting to have for him
he said this what's really crazy is the
number one blog spot for vision on the
internet reached out and they want to
post some of his videos on their post
and they even want to pay him for
letting them post his videos yeah there
is absolutely massive profit by taking
massive action on this information
reason number nine make an impact make
an impact and and when I think about
doing online video men you can make a
major difference a major impact in the
world you could wage awareness for a
cause raise money change lives this is
my good friend and co-author of the book
YouTube secrets
Benji Travis and over like the last
eight years or so we've been partnering
together I mean it's him and his wife's
event but my wife Sony and I have just
participated every year and tried to
contribute whatever influence and energy
and money that we could and just this
last dance number that they did they
raised three hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars for charity and I think
over the last eight years over two
million dollars raised because they
built influence and so they can make a
greater impact one of the companies we
partner with or nonprofits we partner
with that think media is compassion
international and so as a team we
sponsor twenty kids come on just helping
them get educated helping them get out
of poverty and so this absolutely needs
to be connected to purpose in our
opinion that's why we say we want to
help Purpose Driven entrepreneurs and if
you still got it maybe a few reasons
what is one of your reasons what impact
would you want to make in the world I've
learned this that eventually and you
know you might eventually meet your own
needs you you like men I hit a financial
level where like we're somewhat
comfortable we're somewhat settled I've
even heard people say this like yeah you
know we're making enough money for me
and my family we're good here and to be
honest friends some people
they actually think that people trying
to build wealth or selfish I actually
think that if you settle it selfish
because there's so much need in the
world that it's like if you you say well
I don't need more money great why don't
you make more and then give the rest
away because if you are able-bodied if
you've got the power to create wealth if
you got the power to take action and do
these things you can make a massive
difference and impact on people the
final reason reason number 10 is we
close this session reason number ten is
history and legacy history and legacy
let's think for a second about the
legacy you want to build you know like
the next generation the next generation
after that you know for me these are
some videos on my personal channel and
at the time I was just hustling trying
to figure out YouTube we were all over
the place man we had no idea what we
were doing we were like talking about
the amazing spider-man one day of doing
green bean recipes the next day you know
going horseback riding kind of vlog we
had no idea what was going on but but
actually now when I look back I'm so
grateful that I uploaded all these
videos because some day our future
children they're gonna be able to see
this they're gonna be able to see their
father young and weird you know and and
I just think of it as history I think of
it as you know legacy you're gonna be
hearing from Heather in just a moment
and you know when we met just a few
short years ago she had not posted any
videos at all she she didn't have
confidence to get on video in fact the
reason that we kind of met on Twitter
she wanted to learn video but she
punched fear in the face super
uncomfortable she was and she just
started posting videos and now she looks
back in just a few short years at her
channel the the home schoolhouse now
that's at 13,000 subscribers almost
14,000 she's had over 500,000 people
viewer videos but I think one of the
most powerful things is history and
legacy that's her first video ever and
there's young Kaylee her daughter in the
video you know scared that she just got
filmed right Heather and so and this
isn't just three years from now this is
ten years from now 20 years from now
looking back at the journey looking back
at your journey this is why I want
you posting bad videos right no because
one day you're gonna be on this stage or
you're gonna be on your stage or you're
gonna be on whatever stage that you want
to impact and that you're gonna want to
be able to play your first video and be
like ah man that was weird but a lot of
us hide in fear don't we because we're
like all my videos aren't that good yet
hey you want some bad video so you can
have a powerful illustration someday in
the future and if anything just to you
know remember and and be able to kind of
laugh about it with your family and you
know as I close with history and legacy
it actually really reminds me of my
cousin Steven and my cousin Steven
passed away a couple years ago in fact
the anniversary of his death is in just
two days and I passed away at 30 years
old and man I loved him so much in fact
he's one of the greatest inspirations in
my life personally entrepreneur just a
guy that loved people loved God in fact
one thing they people would say about
him is every room he went in if people
better his mission was to leave people
better than when they first met him that
no matter what encounter he just wanted
you to leave the encounter better than
when you first met a man like Steven is
actually one of my reasons when he was
living I felt like we were always
running together fighting together
entrepreneurs together and now that he's
passed on I even think about him and I
imagine him from heaven looking down and
cheering me on you know and and being
someone that is just something so
meaningful and such a motivating reason
in my life
and I think about this years ago he
started a channel called remember when
God and he shared a few videos on there
I was just watching these over the last
couple weeks just you know moved and and
and also thinking man I'm so grateful
though that he has shared this is some
stuff this video right here is about our
family about the reads and that's my
mom's maiden name and and one of the
things about the reads was that we we
loved to eat
you know we loved food and he talks
about that and he's and he's going
through that so I get to remember Steven
I'm so thankful he posted these videos
on this channel just a few videos he
posted he interviewed kind of a his
grandpa grandpa Jasper sent an interview
with him
this is the kind of thing that I think
man when it comes to video we have the
power to document moments don't we we
have the power to capture moments with
our family with our friends you know
with with the the people that matter
most to us in our life and so friends
I'm talking about powerful reasons that
are gonna motivate you when times get
tough I hope you've been writing down
some reasons but I think that ultimately
the greatest reason is connecting to the
legacy and the vision that you have for
your life and your family Maya Angelou
said it this way if you're gonna live
leave a legacy make a mark on the world
that can't be erased so friends now's
the time to go all-in with online video
now is the time to punch fear in the
face the stats are in the facts are in
and now is the time to get strong enough
reasons that gets you out of bed in the
morning to say shoes it's not going how
I thought it was I'm not getting the
views that I thought I'd begin but I'm
gonna get up another day I'm gonna fight
another day I'm gonna punch fear in the
face again I'm gonna rise and grind
again and I'm gonna keep fighting for my
family my future history and legacy
thank you thanks for checking out this
episode we hope you got a ton of value
and if you haven't already subscribe
here to the think marketing show
wherever you're watching or listening
and hey it would mean the world to us if
you would rate and review this show on
Apple podcast as we grow this movement
of purpose-driven content creators we
encourage you to share it with a friend
and we'll see you in the next episode